バンカラジオ俺の名前はエネス最近は
スマブラにはまっている
けけけや
ちゃんゲームばっかやってると頭が悪く
なるわよいい加減やめなさいそしてこいつ
は最強の母親キうっさいな行けけけ行け
行け
けけけけけけけけ
どこだ
ここあすみませんここってどこです
かはうわガが倒してやるよはははどうなっ
てんだ
うわなんだこれスマブラのマリオ
わ待てよこれがスマブラの世界ならあの技
が出せるはず
だしよしよし誰だお前よし今この世界に来
たのそうなんだ早く元の世界に戻りたいん
だけど戻るんだったらビップ城まで進む
ことだねVIP城VIP城に行くには
たくさんの強い敵がいるよしの世界に帰る
んだ俺は行くよしよしよし
よしレ
[音楽]
[拍手]
ゴーゴーやばい攻撃でき
ないおおお
おなんだ
[拍手]
これま
まずいこれ
だかかって
こいおらうわ
じゃあ
ねこれ
はあれこれ止まんない止まんないななんだ
[音楽]
お前
あ止まんないよなんだ
これおうわアイテムだすっげえすっげえ
大量
だけ
う楽勝じゃん
マリオだんだんゴールまで近づいてきた
ペロン敵だ
[音楽]
スワゴ
よし近づけねえじゃないか
[音楽]
ガあいたたたたたたたた
えなんだ
ここここは負けたやつらのたまり場ゲーム
に負けたら一生出れない場所だ一生出れ
ないのかなるかない
かえ
えまだストックが残ってるんだまた戻れる
ぞ
うあと1ストック絶対に負けちゃいけ
ないこれで近づきない
だろ何か咲はないの
かおりおり
おりそこに入れてダメージが溜まっていく
一方だ
[音楽]
ぞくそ向こうから来てくれればこっちの
もんだ
おや
うスマスモール
[音楽]
だすごいペロンよし次に行くぞ
よしリオ
やねちゃん
お屋根ちゃんゲームけっぱしじゃないのあ
[音楽]
やろこいつ今までのやつと格が違うぞ
頑張っ
てななんか新キャラ出るらしいで新キャラ
めっちゃ熱いや
ん
早いはいお疲れ
しどうすれ
ば
わ強
すぎるこれお前たよお前こらお前おい出し
てやったんかってお前おじいちゃん
落ち着いてボケが始まってる
[音楽]
よななんだ突然動きが遅くなったお前男に
なるけやったか
てやるおwi-fi
何これ
もしかして回線が遅延して落が発生してる
のかならば次の攻撃を予測する選択肢は3
つ弱攻撃のコンボ下攻撃横
攻撃さっきまでの癖から考えるに横攻撃の
確率が80%ならば先に回避を
するビゴ
おりあほくっそ腹た
[音楽]
わ向こうはついてるだろうここは煽りを
入れ
[拍手]
[音楽]
て
ついて走ってきた時
[音楽]
になんでこんなんで負けなかんねんもうあ
てか新キャラ発表らしいマジでうんあと
一生したら元の世に
戻れるやばい新キャラの登場だ新キャラ
おい新キャラハプ来たぞやるって見ようぜ
あもう始まるじゃんえ待って待3年ぶりの
新キラ発表ですね
うしいああこれスターウーズ
じゃん6
か
ススえ嘘
やろ
[拍手]
お母さん
なんてことだありえないビップ教が破壊さ
れるなんて相当のバーだぞきっとお母さん
だつむの世界が壊され
[音楽]
ちゃう屋根ちゃん見つけたわ何してんだ
あんたがスマブラのしぎだからこの世界を
壊しに来たのよ
3ゴー
おりゃ
こんなの強すぎなのもう無理
だ僕も仲間になるペロン
よしおお前
ら
よしこれ上に戻れるぞみんな
捕まれ行く
[音楽]
ぞ助けてくれた恩だこのスマブラの世界を
救う
ぞ全員の力を合わせて倒す
ぞ
みんなありがとうこれで
戻れるみんなまた
[音楽]
ねマンマ
みやこれが転送装置か
[音楽]
ワップ
これで一見落着ゲームのやりすぎは良く
なかったのか
なあれお母さんで遊べる
[音楽]
じゃんどどうなってん
だやちゃんゲームのやりすぎはないわ
よちゃちゃチャンネル登録チャンネル登録
チャンネル登録よろしくチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録よろしく
最初はチャンネル登録チャンネル登録
チャンネル
登録
JA